RACHEL: WELCOME BACK TO "FOX &
FRIENDS."
A NEW "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORT SAYS THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE IS MULLING PAYMENTS OF
NEARLY HALF A MILLION DOLLARS TO
ILLEGALS SEPARATED AT THE BORDER
BACK IN 2018.
REPUBLICANS WERE QUICK TO BASH
THE POLICY AS UNACCEPTABLE AND,
QUOTE:  PURE INSANITY.
JOINING US NOW TO REACT IS
ARIZONA ATTORNEY GENERAL MARK
LEBRON VERYBRNOVICH.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS
IDEA THAT WE WOULD PAY ALMOST
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS TO PEOPLE
SEPARATED AT THE BORDER WHO CAME
HERE ILLEGALLY, WHICH, BY THE
WAY, IS ALMOST $50,000 MORE THAN
WHAT WE WOULD PAY THE FAMILY OF
A FALLEN SOLDIER IN OUR WARS.
SO WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> IT’S UNCONSCIONABLE.
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING ON THE BORDER IS REALLY
QUITE FRANKLY UNTHINKABLE AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, RACHEL.
WE HAVE THIS TERRIBLE CRISIS
THAT’S TURNED INTO A
CATASTROPHE.
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
NOW TRYING TO MONETIZE PEOPLE
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
SO THAT WILL END UP WITH EVEN
MORE PEOPLE TRYING TO CROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER ILLEGALLY.
BUT ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW AND I
KNOW, THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE FAR
LEFT TRYING TO REDISTRIBUTED
WEALTH IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO THEY ARE SUBSIDIZING PEOPLE
BREAKING THE LAW, COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
WE WILL GET MORE OF THAT AND
THEY WANT HARDWORKING AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS TO PAY FOR IT AS I
SAID IT’S UNCONSCIONABLE.
IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
RACHEL: MARK, I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING WHAT YOU THINK
THE RATIONALE IS.
JUST SOME OF THE INITIAL
REACTION THAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
AMERICANS OVER THE LAST DAY OR
TWO SINCE WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT
THIS IT’S WILDLY UNPOPULAR
POLITICALLY.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
>> I’M NOT SURE.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE LEARNED IN
SCHOOL OR WE USE TO LEARN IN
SCHOOL BEFORE CRITICAL RACE
THEORY WAS JAMMED DOWN PARENTS’
THROATS IS THAT YOU SHOULDN’T
SUCCUMB DO PEER PRESSURE.
THE FAR LEFT, THE AOCs, THE
CHUCK SCHUMERS AND NANCY
PELOSIS, CARTEL KELLY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE ESSENTIALLY
FAR LEFT NEO MARXISTS.
AND THEY REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THEY WANT TO REDISTRIBUTE
WEALTH.
THEY WANT TO MAKE UP SOCIETY,
AND THEY DON’T CARE.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY THE MIDDLE
CLASS OF THIS COUNTRY AND THEY
ARE GOING TO DO IT BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS.
AND WHAT BREAKS MY HEART AND I
KNOW YOU KNOW THIS, IN ARIZONA,
WE’RE SEEING A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN FENTANYL DEATHS AMONG
TEENAGERS IN PIMA COUNTY NOW THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH REPLACING
CAR ACCIDENTS AND SUICIDES.
THAT’S COMING TO EVERY STATE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
EVERY TAXPAYER IS GOING TO PAY
FOR THIS NOT ONLY THE TAX
DOLLARS BUT THROUGH THEIR
FAMILY’S HEALTH AND WELL-BEING.
RACHEL: NOT TO MENTION WE ARE
INJURING WHO BROUGHT THEIR
CHILDREN HERE.
THIS MIGRANT CARAVAN THAT IS ON
ITS WAY TO OUR BORDER, THEY SAY
IT MAY GOODELL RIO BUT THERE ARE
NOW REPORTS IT CAN COME TO HUMA,
ARIZONA, MARK, I HAVE FRIENDS
WHO LIVE IN HUMA, ARIZONA, THEY
CAN’T EVEN GET THEIR CHILDREN
INTO THEIR HOSPITAL.
THEY HAVE TO TRAVEL HUNDREDS OF
MILES AWAY BECAUSE THEIR
HOSPITALS ARE AND SOCIAL
SERVICES STRAINED.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO PREPARE
FOR THIS CARAVAN COMING THROUGH?
ARE YOU DOING ANYTHING TO STOP
IT.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE ARE TRYING
TO USE -- I’M TRYING TO USE ALL
THE TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL.
THAT INCLUDES MULTIPLE PIECES OF
LITIGATION.
TRYING TO FORCE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE
BUILDING THE WALL.
AND JUST YESTERDAY THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT AGREED TO TAKE OUR
APPEAL, OUR CASE ABOUT THE
PUBLIC CHARGE RULE.
THE PUBLIC CHARGE RULE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION RESCINDED WHICH
BASICALLY SAYS IF YOU COME HERE,
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOURSELF.
YOU CAN’T BE ON PUBLIC BENEFIT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BY
ELIMINATING THAT RULE IS FORCING
OR OVERWHELMING HOSPITALS IN
BORDER STATE HAVING TO PAY FOR
BENEFITS.
EVERYTHING FROM CHILD CARE,
SNAP, HOSPITAL CARE.
AND THE SYSTEM IS OVERWHELMED
AND SO THERE IS NO WAY.
IT’S UNSUSTAINABLE.
THE CARTELS HAVE GAINED
OPERATIONAL CONTROL OF OUR
BORDER AND IT’S NOT JUST AS I
SAID ABOUT THE FISCAL COST.
IT’S ABOUT THE COST WHEN YOU
HAVE DRUG CARTELS THAT ARE
OPERATING WITH IMPUNITY ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
SO WE KNOW AND YOU KNOW THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE A RECORD
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE ILLEGALLY
CROSSING OUR BORDER, MORE THAN
2 MILLION PEOPLE THIS YEAR, IT’S
UNSUSTAINABLE.
RACHEL: ABSOLUTELY.
IT’S WRONG.
MARK, THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US THIS MORNING AND BRINGING
ATTENTION TO BOTH OF THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT ARE RIGHT